[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bonjour fait
eric avons jour j me et bonjour
christophe perez bonjour alors vous êtes
directeur des affaires culturelles ici
en martinique depuis presque un an
maintenant je crois depuis six mois en
fait je vais prolonger déjà deux de 6
mois donc c'est tout récent et alors
vous êtes venu ce matin nous parler des
journées européennes du patrimoine
ces journées qui invite les uns et les
autres le temps de quelques jours en fin
de semaine à se réapproprier et à
visiter notamment quelques fleurons
architecturaux de notre histoire de
notre société mais voilà le tout
accompagné aussi de d'expression
artistique
nous y viendrons d'ailleurs pour la
soirée d'ouverture là aujourd'hui
mais ces journées du patrimoine journée
européenne donc ça se veut avant tout
une opération de proximité n'est pas
tout à fait celle assez la 36e édition
des journées européennes du patrimoine
ça se passe toujours maintenant le
troisième week end de septembre donc ça
devient un rendez-vous et puis on le
conçoit maintenant vraiment commune
comme une fête une fête du patrimoine
une fête à vivre en famille aujourd'hui
ben ce matin vous savez que vous avez
d'abord tous les scolaires qui vont
pouvoir dans cette journée qui s'appelle
lever les yeux un des leviers année
venez vite c'est prévu voilà c'est juste
c'est juste le sujet voilà voilà
mais non mais l'idée l'idée quand je dis
opérations de proximité c'est quoi
d'interpeller je disais les uns et les
autres pour pendant un temps se dire
bien on fait une pause et puis ce qui
paraît lointain où inaperçu dans le flot
de la vie quotidienne dont on s'arrête
et puis on va tout à fait pas non plus
passer à côté de quelque chose et puis
ben vous le regardez pas forcément et là
vous dit tiens il ya un bâtiment jan
alors vous savez que le patrimoine c'est
aussi bien le bâti que l'hymne matériel
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut prendre le
temps de regarder sursis constitue notre
patrimoine et un moment donné ces trois
jours pour faire la fête et bla cette
fête du patrimoine et puis en même temps
vous allez vous avez plus de 120
événements ce qui permet à ce que chacun
et chacune puisse aller à côté de chez
lui ou de chez elle pour pourvoir
quelque chose alors 120 événement c'est
vrai c'est bien c'est tourner ça donne
l'embarras du choix ce fait mais c'est
tant mieux
alors avant d'en venir à cette soirée
d'ouverture les plus jeunes vous disiez
que les plus jeunes sont donc concernés
et vous avez donc une opération un peu
spéciale dédiée donc avec le ministère
d'ailleurs en partenariat avec le
ministère de l'éducation nationale le
ministère de la culture lance la
nouvelle initiative lever les yeux et
donc les béziers en créole tout à fait
mais c'est un moment aujourd'hui ou où
les jeunes vont pouvoir découvrir leur
parti - avec les enseignants c'est
depuis ce jour mise bas ça se passe
aujourd'hui ça se passe aujourd'hui
changé puisque moi moi mon idée c'est
qu'aujourd'hui lorsque nos nos jeunes
scolaires auront visité deux trois
petites choses ils rentreront à la
maison ce soir en disant hé samedi
dimanche et ce qu'on y retourne tous
ensemble est-ce que les deux est
bénéfique pour que pour que nos
auditeurs comprennent bien les béziers
donc c'est une journée d'éducation au
patrimoine et à l'architectural
intentions donc des scolaires de la
maternelle au lycée tout à fait
aujourd'hui il ya des jeunes qui avec
leurs enseignants vont sortir mon faire
des sorties en tout cas vont être
sensibilisés à la question du patrimoine
et c'est un enjeu à la fois pour leurs
regards 1 pour le regard de ces jeunes
sur leur patrimoine mais moi j'ai envie
de dire aussi que c'est un message à
passer aujourd'hui en disant que le
secteur du patrimoine et de la culture
c'est un secteur avec des métiers il
faut des gens il faut des jeunes qui
s'intéressent à comment entretenir le
patrimoine
comment reconstruire rénovée du
patrimoine ici en martinique
comment de
dir architecte comment devenir aussi ce
qu'ils vont parler du patrimoine animer
des animateurs des animatrices du
patrimoine donc il ya plein de métiers
donc donnons envie aux jeunes d'aller
c'est susciter des vocations
et puis également sensibilisé peut-être
même interpellé les enseignants et il ya
un outil également qui est sorti
justement a toujours dans cette même
ordre d'idée connaître le patrimoine
tient de proximité et donc c'est un
vade-mecum quoi une sorte de petit
fascicule qui sort tout à fait c'est une
sorte de kit pédagogique qui permet
facilement aux enseignants et bien voilà
de d'abord quelles sont les actions que
l'on peut mener à la fois aujourd'hui
mais aussi tout le restant de l'année
voilà dans sa aux cadis notre invité ce
matin christophe pommeuse le dac le
directeur des affaires culturelles de
martinique
nous parlons des journées du patrimoine
qui se déroulent tout ce week-end est
donc ça commence dès ce matin et toute
la journée dans les écoles et puis ce
soir donc l'ouverture à la salle
paroissiale du marin à 19 heures et
c'est là qu'on voit que bon parce que
souvent le terme patrimoine et est
associée au passé à l'histoire
on voit là on se dit bon tout ça c'est
une affaire de musées c'est très
poussiéreux et là il y aura l'ouverture
se fait qu'un spectacle de danse urbaine
de zion b-boys alors là bas on l'est on
est dans le patrimoine la vivent
actuelle au guidon du patrimoine bien
vivant puisque l'en je me savais que
tout ce qui se fait aujourd'hui en
création ça sera le patrimoine de demain
tout ce que nous vivons aujourd'hui sous
ce que nous enrichissons aujourd'hui eh
bien ce sera notre patrimoine commun de
demain alors là c'est un petit peu
particulier c'est un clin d'oeil ce soir
l'église du marin sera ouverte
exceptionnellement en nocturne et à ce
moment là il ya un spectacle et oui de
danse urbaine qui sera à la salle
paroissiale
c'était le petit clin d'oeil de ce thème
avertissements comment on met le
patrimoine en dialogue avec la création
mais vous en aurez pour tous les goûts
puisque il y aura un concert d'orgue
dimanche à l'église du lamentin dont
vous voyez l'idée c'est d'associer toute
la création dans sa diversité
on va peut-être mettre en exergue
un ou deux rendez vous parce que bon
c'est vrai que justement le programme
est tellement dense que ça va être
difficile d'en parler longuement détails
mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il ya
aussi alors quand on parle de patrimoine
bon il ya ce qui est organisée là ce que
vous donnez à voir mais il faut aussi le
non seulement le valoriser mais le
préserver ce patrimoine le rehausser
quelquefois le voilà et donc ça c'est
aussi une partie de votre travail de
votre mission à la direction des
affaires culturelles
notre mission c'est aussi une
réservation à la préservation et puis
l'entretien et la rénovation
parce que vous savez qu'on a été
beaucoup de bâtiments vous il ya plus de
118 monument historique c'est-à-dire des
monuments on s'est mis d'accord qu'il
faut les préserver qu'il faut les les
guest des générations futures
sur ces bâtis sur ses bâtiments sur ces
monuments historiques
la plus grande partie aujourd'hui ce
sont des édifices religieux
ensuite il ya des édifices dié à la
distillerie où as tu du patrimoine
économique et industriel et puis après
vous avez des particuliers aussi qui est
ce assez extraordinaire sur week-end qui
enlève ont décidé d'ouvrir les portes
d'endroits qui d'habitude sont fermés
tout au long de l'année donc l'enjeu oui
c'est de comment restaurer ce patrimoine
notamment avec les défis les défis
climatiques comment je sais pas - nos
églises notre fort nous nous notre
patrimoine va pouvoir résister aux six
nouveaux séismes cyclones et comment on
rénove et ici en martinique on acquiert
des compétences bien particulière sur
comment rénover un monument on ne fait
pas la même manière ailleurs et avec les
normes tout contraignant du du moment
mais tout ça alors souvent basses à un
coup des fois même un coût élevé
alors des fois il s'agit de bâtiments
d'ouvragé privés des fois public en tout
cas ce que je veux dire c'est que dans
toute cette affaire là on voit bien que
l'état ait aussi dans un dans un état
d'esprit de partenariat public-privé
quoi hein le dernier exemple le plus
parlant c'est le musée de saint pierre
qui a été rénové et donc comme ça à
préserver avec l'aide de notamment de la
fondation gbh donc du privé tout à fait
dans le cadre de ce qu'on appelle une
délégation de service public et ça c'est
des fois ça heurte quelques-uns mais
aujourd'hui ce qui est intéressant c'est
que vous y en ait un engouement des
martiniquaises et des martiniquais pour
leur patrimoine et que tout ça est
affaire de synergies aujourd'hui vous
avez plusieurs acteurs qui sont présents
vous avez la fondation du patrimoine
vous avez des fondations privées
nous nous avons contractualisé avec la
ctm plus de 9 millions sur le juste le
patrimoine bâti
je vous parle même pas du patrimoine
immatériel lorsque je veux dire c'est
qu'on a besoin
ben que tous les acteurs s'intéressent
s'intéresse le secteur et je vais vous
dire une chose je pense mais ça c'est
mon ma petite observation depuis
quelques mois je pense que le patrimoine
n'est pas qu'une enjeux qu un enjeu
financier ou d'argent je pense qu'il
faut de la ressource il faut des hommes
et des femmes qui vont développer des
métiers on a besoin de gens qui suivent
les chantiers on a besoin de gens qui
vont des végétalisée entretenir les
ruines à saint pierre on a besoin on a
besoin de tous ses métiers
il faut absolument conforme notre source
ici en martinique ouais donc c'est une
affaire collective a vraiment tout à
fait toute la société finalement qui
doit s'investir dans cette préservation
et cette valorisation du patrimoine
il pourrait donc valorisé enfin parler
du patrimoine il faut ya aussi des
ouvrages et notamment vous vous avez mis
en exergue la publication en matière
patrimoniale de deux deux ouvrages l'un
dans la collection parcours du
patrimoine sur l'église du sacré-coeur
de balata puis un hors série
connaissance des arts consacré au
patrimoine de lamartine quelques mots là
dessus et puis on va terminer sur tout
un peuple
si vous avez des petits des petits
ouvrages sur alors là c'est sûr l'église
de balata donc et plutôt est plutôt
intéressant puisque aujourd'hui vous
avez des églises du xxème siècle qu'il
faut sur lequel il faut regarder un
portait un regard aussi notamment genou
bon je parle aussi de l'église
sainte-thérèse qui est un enjeu de
rénovation aujourd'hui donc voilà donc
vous avez d'un petit guide comme ça qui
était fait pour le coup tenez avec la en
partenariat avec la fondation clément
c'est aussi une ouvrage qui a été édité
et puis vous avez là hier est sorti a
été lancée vous pouvez trouver
maintenant dans les kiosques une revue
un spécial connaissance des arts hors
série sur patrimoine patrimoine au
pluriel un patrimoine de la martinique
et là vous avez evian tu as une belle
revue en tout cas qui retrace toutes les
patrimoines et gens me dire le
patrimoine et le matrimoine parce qu'il
ya aussi la place de ce que font les
femmes et les hommes qui sont bâtisseuse
et bâtisseur donc je crois qu'il faut
essayer de reconnaître tout ce que
toutes celles et tous ceux qui ont
contribué à ce que nous avons
aujourd'hui c'est à dire ce patrimoine à
entretenir et à transmettre
vous avez dit matrimoine tout à fait la
première fois que j'entends ça allait
nous reste que peu de temps
christophe gomes juste dans tout le
programme j'ai relevé qu' effectivement
on pas on pense beaucoup aux monuments
historiques notamment quand bon voilà
mais par exemple il ya une visite qui se
fait aux bassins de radoub ben à fort de
france une visite commentée présentation
par une entreprise de l'histoire du
fonctionnement de ce patrimoine
technique et maritimes du grand port de
la martinique bon bah voilà là aussi
c'est un peu surprenant annoncé des
pythies c'est enfin un endroit vous avez
une petit une cale sèche qui encore en
fonctionnement qui pas tenir accueillir
jusqu'à deux bateaux jusqu'à 180 mètres
et donc vous avez un endroit qui encore
fonctionnement qui grâce à ce
fonctionnement entretien parce que le
simple est donc allé visiter s'est
jamais ouvert là y'a une ya une
possibilité de voir
fonctionne ce patrimoine là avec une
entreprise qui le rend bien vivant oui
c'est des petites pépites comme ça vous
avez dans le programme et n'hésitait pas
aussi de la technique de la technologie
dans cette affaire là très bien merci
christophe poumès les dix minutes sont
déjà passés et bien bonne journée du
patrimoine à toutes et à tous c'est
jimmy est déjà prêt moi j'ai déjà là je
suis en phase du programme